Formulation aids
with which you will be presented in your next factual analysis
1 to 2 minutes can be better
It is always right and important
that you initiate
work out the problem or
turn out
That is
you just start with the sentence um the text
the excerpt of the articles
deals with the problem
the excessive use of cell phones,
for example
of teenagers
is now only n example
or alternatively you could also use um
the author deals with the question
OB the frequent use of the cell phone
poor on the concentration of adolescents
affects only 1 example
when you then
the problem or the topic
of the facts
have correctly recorded
you just go on
and simply To find out
Could you say something like introduce
the author begins with the thesis that
further,
he claims in this context the
and then he just goes on with um
He bases his argument on the thesis that
and simply around
I do not know
perhaps to work out n contrast
um on the one hand is listed
the opposite is held the
alone if you only have all these formulations
can bind into a context
that is,
which can also apply sensibly
you have in any case already good
what worked out
And if you,
for example
on the linguistic design of the text
should enter or analyze that
you can just see down here
Something like his argument
finds particular reinforcement in the use of
Repeats or
expressive punctuation mark whatever
there are only examples
Exactly you can say um
Through the use of
the and the stylistic means
becomes particularly clear
that then interprets
or increased use of
hm hm in line hm hm
and in this respect it is possible to emphasize in particular the
these are now simply small formulation tools
But if you work with it
you have in any case already well analyzed what
yes And I hope this helped you